[Music]
all right here's how the survey works we
asked three celebrities to complete a
phrase our first phrase was the hardest
thing about having my first baby was
julie bowen wrote sleep deprivation
natalie portman wrote the baby's
constant crying
snooki wrote knowing exactly when to
turn him over in the tanning bed
hurricane isaac veered away from the
republican convention because
al roker wrote prevailing headwinds sent
it further west wolf blitzer wrote it
was attracted by the warm water off the
gulf coast
mitt romney wrote it received my
personal check for 10 billion dollars
that worked yeah you can do that
if
if i were a tree i'd be
harrison ford wrote an oak
amy poehler wrote an orange blossom
lindsay lohan wrote a tree driving a car
into another tree
i owe most of my success to seth green
wrote good parents who taught me to
always work hard
will ferrell wrote being fearless with
comedy
david hasselhoff wrote a rare
neurological disorder that prevents me
from experiencing shame
i know that disease well
an excellent source of information on
the female body is tina fey wrote our
bodies ourselves
gwyneth paltrow wrote women's health
magazine
representative todd aiken wrote jeff
foxworthy's the rednecks guide to lady
parts
yeah good it's a good book good book
will i am is broadcasting his latest
song from the surface of mars because
nasa's charles bolden wrote it's a great
way to showcase the technology of the
curiosity rover justin bieber wrote it's
an excellent publicity stunt
william wrote no one on this planet
wants to hear it
he's being way too hard on himself yeah
this presidential election will prove
what americans truly want is barack
obama wrote a solid investment in their
middle class
mitt romney wrote smaller government and
common sense leadership
paul ryan wrote a vice president with
the cold lifeless eyes of a serial
murderer
those keepers here
sleep
after a night with the guys my
girlfriend wants to know vince vaughn
wrote how much i drank
derek jeter wrote exactly who i was with
prince harry wrote why the tip of my
penis is covered in pool chalk
[Applause]
i'm just besides from england i know i
just figured it out
as a kid i loved my cat because he was
so julianne moore wrote cuddly
wendy williams wrote playful
larry king wrote saber-toothed
[Applause]
[Music]
those those always delight me
my grandmother used to call me paul rudd
wrote apple cheeks
kate beckinsale wrote sweetie pie
haralda rivera wrote douche nozzle
[Applause]
now
and finally i've been following the fate
of jailed russian punk band [ __ ] riot
because
michael moore wrote they are taking on
the excesses of the putin regime
and hathaway wrote they put themselves
at risk for political freedom bill
clinton wrote i get a google alert every
time there's a story about the words
[ __ ] and jail
[Applause]
well i believe our work here is done